The guys.
Tim Ferriss here,
I talk a lot about morning routines on the Tim Ferriss show with 200 plus world
class experts.
Now you tend to spot certain patterns and I'm also a fan of experimenting with
some of the weirder stuff.
So what do I do at night?
What is my evening wind down protocol and what do I do if I'm on the road and I
don't have something like a sauna or an ice bath or these very space and
resource consuming contraptions that I might want to have,
right?
Like the chilly pad not going to travel with the chilly pad even though Rick
Rubin and Laird Hamilton,
all these people,
Kelly Starr at swear by it,
right?
It's a big ass contraption.
So what can you do?
I will show you a few of the tools of the trade as far as I'm concerned that I'm
using right now prebid to help me sleep because as someone who's had or had I
should say,
and Somnia for decades,
sleep has always been compromised and as a result it is now one of my highest
priorities.
Show you some biochemical goodies.
This is certainly a cheaper version of it,
but this is phosphatidyl serin,
right.
What is this fossil fuel?
Sarian sometimes called P s fossil Sirion was recommended to me by an MD who
noticed that he,
since he was wearing a continuous glucose monitor,
meaning he's not a diabetic,
but he was wearing a Dexcom device that's inserted into the skin so that he'd
get a read out on his iPhone at all times.
I'm a graph of his blood glucose and he's having trouble sleeping and what he
realized was because he had so many projects running,
he does a lot more than just handle high end medical clients.
He was having bursts of cortisol at night,
so just when he was trying to go to bed,
he'd get a burst of cortisol that would cause the release of glucose,
I suppose by breaking down glycogen in the liver or muscle and
phosphatidylserine specifically.
It's not like an ambient or anything along those lines or a Melatonin,
let's say that's a circadian trigger.
What this is doing is blunting cortisol release.
So by blunting the cortisol release,
taking this before bed,
you then blood the glucose release which causes you to wake up,
like you're having a sugar high in the middle of the night and Lo and behold,
his sleep quality improved.
So I don't use this all the time.
Cortisol is a very important hormone.
You don't want to inhibit it completely or you would die.
So,
uh,
occasional use maybe when I'm first getting settled in a new airbnb or hotel
foster [inaudible] very,
very useful.
That is number one.
Number two,
now I won't actually carry this in my bag,
but as soon as I land somewhere I will buy one of these or use instacart to get
a bottle.
It depends on how long it would be there,
whether it's large or small of Brag,
raw,
unfiltered apple cider vinegar.
And I will have at least one or two tablespoons of this in water when I wake up.
And also when I go to bed,
I cannot explain exactly why this has the affected does.
Just mechanistically,
I don't know how to exactly explain a plausible mechanism,
but there are two things that I use is for it.
The first is immune support,
so having apple cider vinegar and also whey protein in the mornings.
Just through some incredibly harrowing book launches and other incredible
deadlines.
I've noticed supplements,
anything I might be doing to support my immune system and I just,
I get less sick.
Uh,
if I do become sick,
it's of less duration and severity.
So apple cider vinegar,
helpful for that.
It would appear.
Also very helpful as a tip from Seth Roberts.
Phd Sadly has passed professor emeritus at uh,
believe it was UC Berkeley who suggested for insomnia,
one tablespoon or two tablespoons of apple cider vinegar,
one tablespoon of raw honey mixed in hot water.
And for,
I'd say eight out of 10 people that just knocks you out.
So if I'm really having trouble sleeping,
I'll also use that.
Now,
oddly enough,
you'd think,
well,
wait a second,
if I'm using this to blunt glucose release and then I'm drinking this,
not at the same time,
I don't use these together with honey.
Wouldn't honey also triggered the same type of sugar high for whatever reason,
done 20 or 30 minutes before bed.
It has the opposite effect,
so go figure.
All right,
these are,
these are two now beyond that.
Oh,
very frequently do a slant board workout,
which isn't really a workout because I'm really holding it.
It was step on this in different ways.
This is designed by Eric Orton,
who became famous from born to run.
This is the Frio Frio year.com Slint born slash wobble board.
I have no connection to this company.
Easy to travel with.
I mean,
super simple to throw in a bag and I will spend 30 to 60 seconds,
uh,
in different ways,
positioning my foot and improving my stability in the lower leg.
Right?
Super easy to travel with.
I've had a huge ROI on very little exercise doing that.
Then I'm going to do what?
The supple leopard himself,
Kelly Star it would recommend.
I've few devices that I use to activate a,
I want to say the parasympathetic.
Am I getting that right to go to bed?
I'm pretty sure it's pressing pathetic.
Maybe it's sympathetic.
I'm sure the Internet will let me know.
But to effectively downregulate my system and help with getting to sleep,
there are few types of soft tissue manipulation that I liked you.
So this is a device from the Rad company,
Rad.
This is from Rad roller.
This is for your back.
You can use it for the legs as well,
but you'll notice the spine fits nicely in this little groups.
You're not jacking up,
uh,
your vertebra rolling on something that's too hard and it's very small.
The next is something that I will use just for it band primarily and Vastus
lateralis that's on the side of the leg.
So you're really just going to be rolling your legs out like this.
And I will also roll out my hamstrings.
But after a long day of standing and or sitting,
uh,
this is a godsend.
So these knobby knobby tires are from,
uh,
the rumble roller company.
I don't know if that's the name of their parent company.
They're also stands that you can put these in.
They're tiny and you can stick this on the floor and say,
roll your feet out on these.
But I use this primarily on my thighs and hamstrings.
Uh,
there are many different devices you can find.
If you looked for rolling stick,
you could find other options and you don't have to do necessarily all of these,
but I will almost always do at least one of them.
Uh,
prior to bed,
my prior to bed,
I mean half hour part of that.
Then this,
what is this?
This is a deflated ball that you can blow up with your mouth and then lay on so
that it is pressing into your abdominal cavity.
It really just roll around if you don't know what you're.
So as his look that up p s o a s deep deep muscle that is very painful to have
someone work on manually.
Uh,
but you can,
you can really turn your body down a few gears so you can downshift in such a
way that is very helpful prior to bed by rolling around in your stomach for
literally 30 seconds to 60 seconds.
I find that little to be very helpful.
And then last,
I'm going to show you an APP that I find it very,
very helpful.
And the APP is called apnea trainer.
It's designed for free divers.
I'm not a free diver.
I use it just to relax prior to going to bed and then also improves lung
capacity.
So that's apnea trainer and you can see I've already set effectively the
duration that I would like to use and there's crony,
I'm breathing.
And then there's a regular
apnea training and it's based on your maximum inhaled time.
So this is going to be a little boring for a second,
but you'll get the idea.
So we'll try to make sure he can get the audio.
Inhale,
five,
four,
three,
two,
one,
hold your breath.
Yeah.
Ten five,
four,
three,
two,
one.
Exhale.
Ten five,
four,
three,
two,
one.
Inhale,
five,
four,
three,
two,
one.
Hold your breath.
You get the idea.
And if you do that,
forget about luck.
Meditation's Great.
But for the vast majority of people who are averse to it,
don't think about it that way.
Just think about it as a five minute period of breath work and do say 10 cycles
of that.
Where in this particular case,
uh,
the ratio is one,
four,
two.
So if I breathe in for five seconds,
I'm holding for 20 and then I'm exhaling for 10 and you do that,
especially listening to some hypnotic robotic female voice counting off for you.
You do that for five minutes,
your sleep will come a lot faster and a lot harder than it would otherwise.
And a super,
super simple,
I'm not sure how much the APP costs a few dollars.
It's not expensive and that folks is effect in effect,
my little travel yield.
So all of these things that I put right here minus this,
which I would order a or by when I land or get through instacart or something.
All of this just came out of my suitcase,
which is about 20 feet that direction because I just got back from an extended
trip and this was sitting in there.
It is my Goto toolkit for winding down in the evening or end or as a pre bed
ritual.
So there you have it.
Good luck.
Sleep.
Well,
thanks for watching guys.
I hope you enjoyed it,
and if you want to see more,
I have some fantastic stuff coming,
including collaborations.
Just click here and you'll be the first to see it.